[Musique]
Véronique prince Émilie Nicolas Marie
Vastel bonsoir bonsoir un mot Émilie
Nicolas je sais pas si vous connaissez
la journaliste iranienne à qui on a
parlé à Paris était pas Paris mais bref
en France
qui revient sur ce courage des femmes
iraniennes une journée comme aujourd'hui
le souligner c'est quand même important
absolument tout ce qu'elle a dit est
extrêmement important je pense que ce
qui est important de savoir dans le 8
mars c'est que la journée internationale
c'est la journée internationale pour les
droits des femmes donc c'est pas
seulement au Québec au Canada c'est un
mouvement mondial et il y a beaucoup de
recul en ce moment pour la condition des
femmes il y a bien sûr en Iran on venait
on vient juste d'en parler on
Afghanistan aussi avec les régimes des
talibans juste ici ou ceux aux
États-Unis le recul du droit
l'avortement dans la dernière année donc
il y a plein d'exemples comme ça qu'on
pourrait prendre un peu partout dans le
monde c'est sûr qu'est-ce qui se passe
en Iran particulièrement inquiétant mais
vraiment le
secrétaire général de l'ONU parler au
début de la semaine donc un rapport de
onuf femme qui vient de qui dit que à ce
statique il y a tellement eu de recul
dans la condition féminine dans le monde
surtout depuis la pandémie qu'à se
statique égalité homme-femme sera pas
atteinte avant 300 ans
donc vraiment beaucoup de travail à
faire on faut continuer recule donc ok
ce qui ne recule pas Marie Vasselle je
vous relance sur un autre sujet ce qui
ne recule pas c'est le sujet chinois à
Ottawa l'opposition est revenue à la
charge je vais vous faire entendre un
certain nombre d'extraits aujourd'hui
qu'on vient tout de suite en parler
canadien veulent savoir exactement ce
qui s'est passé et c'est pour ça qu'une
enquête indépendante et rigoureuse par
un rapporteur spécial par NASA par nsira
vont être la façon de pouvoir assurer
les Canadiens
qui sont encore ce matin encore une
information qui sont ce matin qui nous
apprend que tout doux savaient des
choses qui
ignoraient aujourd'hui donc je pense
qu'il y a un problème de mémoire qui est
néfaste pour le Canada je pense que je
suis toujours étonnant
au moins un de ces candidats libérales
éteint impliqués dans une réseau
d'ingérence étrangère est-ce que ce
candidat fait partie maintenant du
caucus ou du cabinet du premier ministre
oui ou non comme moi-même et la
conseillère la sécurité nationale
l'avant déclaré l'automne dernier nous
n'avons aucune information sur des
candidats fédéraux ayant reçu de
l'argent de la Chine
Marie est-ce qu'on en sait plus comment
on peut décrire l'état du sujet
aujourd'hui
la réponse que vous avez présenté de
Monsieur Trudeau en chambre c'est
essentiellement la seule réponse qui
était
factuelle toutes ces autres réponses à
Monsieur pollièvre aux député du blog au
député du NPD c'était essentiellement de
répéter qu'il veut confier à deux
comités un rapporteur spécial qui
demeure qu'on attend encore dont on
attend encore l'identité que c'est à eux
qu'il faut confier une enquête sur la
suite des choses
qu'il veut rassurer les Canadiens mais
que ce sont les meilleurs forums pour le
faire donc bref on a rien appris de plus
de la bouche de Monsieur Trudeau ce qui
disait ce matin son arrivée au caucus
les images qu'on voit et qui le dit en
anglais c'était que bien franchement peu
importe ce qu'il dit les Canadiens
continueront d'avoir des questions sur
ce que le gouvernement a fait ou n'a pas
fait et on dirait que Monsieur Trudeau
se cache un peu derrière ça pour ne rien
dire que de toute façon les gens ne le
croiraient pas sauf que ça commence à
être légèrement intenable ce silence il
y avait un sondage récemment gustrie qui
disait que 53% des Canadiens pensent que
la gérance chinoise a posé une menace
sérieuse à la démocratie du Canada 53%
aussi qui pensent que la réponse du
gouvernement n'est pas assez corsée dans
ce dossier l'homme c'est une minorité
canadienne qui pense que l'élection de
2021 a été volé mais c'est quand même
42% des répondants conservateurs et 35%
des répondants bloqués il y a un
problème monsieur Trudeau nous répète
qu'on ne peut pas tomber dans la partie
zannerie mais un problème démocratique
là que ce silence note silence là ne
règle pas du tout Émilie Véronique on a
l'impression qu'ils vont voir au cours
des prochains jours si l'histoire
s'apaise un peu il y aura un nom un jour
de se rapporteur qui va décider si on a
besoin d'une enquête approfondie c'est
un peu ça qu'on soit du côté des
libéraux Émilie j'imagine
c'est ce qu'on souhaite après
c'est pour revenir sur ce que sur ce que
Marie disait en fait le premier ministre
un peu raison de dire qu'à ce stati peu
importe ce qu'il dit il y a beaucoup de
gens qui vont pas le croire la question
c'est pourquoi est-ce que ça lui a pris
autant de temps par exemple avant de
nommer un rapporteur ou avant de faire
un geste autre que de seulement rassuré
les gens sur les processus qui sont déjà
en place sur lesquels on connaît très
peu de choses donc là puisque fait très
peu trop peu trop tard maintenant il est
pris avec cette patate chaude là qui
était sur de lui revenir en pleine face
une fois que le Parlement revenaient en
session après après la relâche et c'est
ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui donc oui on
l'attendrateur on lui souhaite d'un
mieux le plus rapidement possible
peut-être que ça peut faire éloigner le
cycle de nouvelles de lui qu'on va
supposer les questions sur cette
personne-là plutôt que sur lui
personnellement mais ça risque d'être
très compliqué pour lui dans les
prochaines semaines à moins qu'il y ait
quelque chose de concret qui évolue sur
ce dossier là le rapporteur monsieur
Poirier hier c'est quand même assez
drôle en chambre mais ça arrive dans les
échanges quand il a dit c'est un nouveau
concept qu'on connaissait pas est-ce que
ça vient qu'un costume etc c'est quoi un
rapporteur Véronique si je vous parle de
ça c'est que on a l'impression puis
Marie et Émilie disent un peu ça que la
communication de Monsieur Trudeau depuis
quoi deux trois semaines a été
déficiente là-dessus qui aurait fallu
peut-être agir plus tôt avec des choses
plus faciles à comprendre pour tout le
monde Véronique puis là la situation
dans laquelle il se trouve c'est-à-dire
une position défensive ça peut durer
longtemps puis on peut penser que c'est
une stratégie politique de nommer par
exemple un rapporteur indépendant
spécial parce que le temps de le nommer
le temps qu'il fasse son rapport ça
permet à Justin Trudeau de gagner du
temps mais pendant ce temps-là jour
après jour il va se faire questionner
puis peut-être que son équipe espère
secrètement qu'il y a une diversion
quelque part puis une diversion ça peut
arriver n'importe quand là il suffit
qu'il y a une pandémie une guerre en
Ukraine on sait ce que c'est là dans
l'actualité mais d'ici là ça peut durer
longtemps la position dans laquelle il
se trouve et plus il va essayer de
repousser le moment plus ça peut faire
mal moi j'ai déjà fait le parallèle puis
je le refais encore aujourd'hui ça me
fait penser à l'époque de jean-charrey
avant qu'il déclenche la commission
Charbonneau ça lui avait pris deux ans
puis rappelez-vous il avait créé
l'escouade Marteau après ça l'Unité
anticollusion du ministère des
Transports le bureau de la lutte contre
la corruption le pack après deux ans il
y avait dit ouais là on va la déclencher
l'enquête publique donc est-ce que c'est
ce qui attend juste un truc d'eau mais
d'un autre côté je remarque peut-être
que mes collègues à Ottawa vont pouvoir
aussi enchaîner là-dessus mais en même
temps c'est pas son premier sa première
crise politique il y avait eu la gacane
Witcher it SNC-Lavalin Mackenzie il y a
pas tellement longtemps puis à chaque
fois il y a quand même réussi à passer
au travers mais là il y a l'usure du
pouvoir
cinéma pour conclure là dessus oui mais
beaucoup ont souligné qu'une enquête
publique c'est pas évident non plus
c'est un peu évanescent ce sujet là
Marie là on fait pas venir des des
agences secrètes en disant dites-nous
tout ce que vous pensez savoir sur
l'autre sur la Chine c'est pas si simple
que ça leur
fait mais à ce qui ne satisfait pas
l'opposition ou les Canadiens je suis
d'accord avec Véronique probablement que
le bureau du premier ministre j'espère
qu'il y a quelque chose qui surviennent
qui change le poste comme on dit sauf
que le problème c'est qu'on ne sait pas
non plus quand est-ce qu'il y aura une
élection qui pourrait changer le poste
et là on ne parle pas d'un scandale
éthique comme la gacane on parle d'un
doute de canadien envers le processus
électoral il pourrait en avoir une
bientôt une élection fédérale il est là
le problème la stratégie de
communication des libéraux de toujours
dire on attend on attend on fait rien
finalement on consulte ça ne marche pas
dans ce cas-ci je pense parce que le
problème est tout autre on parle pas
d'un problème éthique un problème
politique on parle d'un problème
démocratique
et oui qui mène la relation de confiance
qu'on doit avoir avec le processus
politique et miliconclusion
aux États-Unis ça fait longtemps déjà
quelques années qu'on ait pris avec avec
le récit de l'élection volée on sait ce
que ça donne et il faut comprendre que
ce récit politique là a un impact sur la
manière dont plusieurs Canadiens
reçoivent cette nouvelle là ici de se
dire ici aussi c'est possible donc non
seulement ce que Marie dit sur le fait
que il peut avoir une élection qui s'en
vient sans que ces questions-là soient
réglées c'est très vrai mais en plus ça
peut avoir un impact sur le climat dans
laquelle cette élection-là pourrait se
passer de la même manière dont aux
États-Unis c'est devenu un enjeu
sécuritaire la méfiance que les gens ont
développé que certaines personnes ont
développé envers la processus
électoral-main donc faut que ça règle et
ça rien à voir avec les autres scandales
et ça presse très bien mais on est ok
c'est parfait
est-ce que je vais à la sac où je vais à
margarno je vais aller à la SAC si vous
me permettez c'est croire que je vous
propose les sujets je pense que j'ai
allons à la SAQ parce que Véronique
ce matin la ministre fraîchement
débarquée d'Europe qui annonce une série
de mesures que le directeur de la SAQ
nous avait pas mal dit aussi mais je
chantais qui hier il voulait on lui
avait dit laisse à la ministre le soin
d'annoncer tout seul en boniforme demain
matin est-ce que le gros derrière eux
vous pensez croît-il vers unique prince
de cette crise on se croise les doigts
c'est dur à dire mais très certainement
le fait qu'une ministre débarque et
Geneviève Guilbaud qui est quand même
réputé pour avoir une expérience en
matière de gestion de crise c'est sûr
que les gens à la salle doivent marcher
les festérés comme on dit parce que
quand une ministre arrive sur place là
ça mène pression très importante sur les
gens de la haute direction le four que
ça marche parce que elle elle veut des
résultats et très rapidement donc c'est
clair que peut-être que ça va faire
bouger les choses plus vite que les
solutions vont être mises en place pour
rapidement dans les prochains jours mais
en même temps la sac probablement eu un
problème de communication pourquoi on a
entendu parler de ce nouveau logiciel là
il y a seulement quelques semaines alors
que c'est en préparation de plus si
longtemps est-ce qu'on aurait pas dû
mener une campagne de communication avec
des publicités partout je veux dire on
manque pas de tribune maintenant avec
les médias sociaux numériques les médias
généralistes est-ce que partout on
aurait dû davantage dire ça s'en vient
préparez-vous si vous avez des choses à
faire renouveler attendez pas tout à la
dernière minute commencez maintenant
donc il y a peut-être eu lacune au
niveau de la communication puis demander
quatre preuves et quatre numéros un
permis de conduire mes relations
sociales numéro de permis de conduire
numéro de je sais pas trop quoi l'autre
c'était beaucoup demandé à des gens
comme interface sympathique Émilie non
c'est sûr que c'est beaucoup demandé je
pense que de manière générale le
problème c'est que lorsqu'il est
question de virage numérique il y a
beaucoup de gens qui réalisent pas à
quel point la littérature numérique
c'est pas faire de tout le monde il y a
des enjeux générationnels il y a des
enjeux de littératie tout court encore
au Québec c'est pas tout le monde qui a
tous ces documents là il y a des enjeux
linguistiques aussi pour pour beaucoup
de personnes donc il y a un ensemble
d'enjeux d'accessibilité là-dedans que
oui c'est sûr que pour plusieurs
personnes ça fasse sa facilite la faire
et on se dit bon message si au moins
c'est les gens pour qui s'effacent vont
en ligne ça élimine les films pour les
fils pour les autres mais je pense qu'il
y a un une pensée magique souvent
lorsqu'il est question des virages
numériques ça donne par exemple au
fédéral des crises aussi de hamsonage
quand on pense que tout va se faire en
ligne que les gens la compréhension de
comment ça fonctionne en ligne ça donne
des occasions aussi à des sports mais
essentiellement des personnes et
fraudeurs de prendre de de de
d'utiliser des personnes vulnérables
donc un ensemble d'enjeux que je pense
qu'il devrait être pris pour au sérieux
au-delà de cette crise là qui va finir
par se régler là je pense que si on
prend mieux en compte j'étais là à venir
on reste en évitez d'autres problèmes on
aurait aimé poser ces questions entre
autres ericaires le ministre responsable
la transformation numérique et a donné
une entrevue à nos collègues il y a pas
le temps de donner notre vie à notre
bureau politique il va peut-être le
trouver ce soir on nous dit bref je
referme la parenthèse Marie Vatel
ça fait penser aux problèmes des
passeports mais c'est comme un fouillis
et un manque de préparation en tout cas
qui a fait qu'il y a beaucoup de
citoyens qui ont été mal servis je pense
que la similitude elle est là dans le
sens où on c'est un peu tiré dans le
pied nous-même en ne prévoyant pas dans
le cas des passeports la réouverture des
bureaux parce qu'on est interdit aux
gens de renouveler leur passeport
pendant la pandémie on ne permettait pas
et dans ce cas-ci comme le disait
Véronique on n'a pas vu venir ce gros
virage là pour avoir vu la crise des
passeports je ne suis pas convaincue que
malgré toute la bonne volonté de
Geneviève Guilbaud ça serait aussi
rapidement que ça on a vu avec les
passeports qu'un arriéré c'est long
pour reprendre le contrôle on donne aux
gens un délai de trois mois pour
renouveler le permis de conduire mais
ces gens-là vont s'accumuler dans la
file d'attente là je suis pas certaine
que ça se règle ici facilement que ça et
surtout pour la suite comme dit Émilie
ce gouvernement là qui nous parle d'un
virage numérique depuis des années je
comprends ce que la ministre guilbody il
faut le faire on est en 2023 la nouvelle
génération est rendue là mais si c'est
comme ça que ça se passe dans le cas
d'une agence gouvernementale le gros
virage à l'échelle du gouvernement du
Québec attaché votre sucre parce que
s'il y a rien de réglisse ça va être un
peu excuser l'expression ça va être un
peu rock n' roll donc je trouve que ça
soulève des inquiétudes à ce niveau là
aussi là pour pour la suite des choses
quand on va l'implanter à l'échelle de
tout le gouvernement ça fait réfléchir
sur les interfaces en tout cas elle est
simplicité puis comme dit Émilie c'est
pas tout le monde qui est
que les mêmes outils pour aller
rapidement sur un site puis je peux vous
en parler bon
margarno margarnoul il reste deux
minutes et demi Véronique tour de table
Marcano qui dit adieu à la politique
astronaute homme qui respectait de ses
pères
Ottawa qui avait des problèmes aussi
avec le projet de loi sur la langue
française que ça a joué ou pas on sait
pas mais voilà qui le parle
effectivement puis lui il dit il
attendait de déposer le rapport de du
comité de l'aide médicale à mourir sur
lequel il présidait puis on comprend la
raison mais en même temps est-ce qu'on
peut quand même se demander s'il y avait
pas un lien brisé avec Justin Trudeau
pas juste par rapport à ce projet de loi
là mais aussi dans le passé il avait
refusé le poste d'ambassadeur à Paris là
c'est sûr que dans son comté ça devait
pas être évident non plus de se
retrouver sur la clôture entre les deux
communautés linguistines linguistiques
anglophones et francophone donc le
prochain député va se retrouver un peu
avec cette patate chaude là mais
sûrement libéral parce que c'est un
château fort ouest
je vous prêche Émilie
un peu controversé peut-être mais en
fait je pense que c'est important quand
même des hommes
m'organisent pas politiciens carrière il
est talent politique qui avait déjà une
longue carrière avant notamment comme
astronaute il y a fait plusieurs années
de service il était ministre il est plus
ministre et député derrière banc pour un
ensemble de raisons c'est correct pour
les gens de tourner la page en politique
ça on se dit est-ce que si est-ce que ça
oui c'est sûr qu'il y a toujours un
récit mais si on veut pas que les gens
s'éternisent en politique indéfiniment
c'est correct que des gens démissionnent
des fois passent à autre chose ça fait
partie de la vie politique c'est aussi
ça peut être très simple si sentait que
les défis qu'elle va remplir ont été
remplies c'est ça oui mais des fois j'ai
l'impression qu'on cherche des on
cherche alors
moi j'ai pas de problème à ce que
politique après 15 ans de carrière en
politique une carrière avant à 74 ans il
a mérité sa retraite monsieur Ganot mon
petit malaise c'est quand notre vie à la
intéresse peut-être dans un élan de
candeur il a dit que s'il avait su qu'il
ne resterait pas ministre des Affaires
étrangères après l'élection de 2021 il
ne serait serait peut-être pas
représenté soit mais une fois qu'on se
représente je trouve qu'on finit son
mandat et on attend que le mandat se
termine avant de quitter c'est excusé à
ses commettant moi il est là un peu mon
malaise avec on comprend très bien et
vous avez dit Marie je vous cite bientôt
peut-être des élections fédérales je
vous ai pas relancé bientôt c'est large
un an et demi un an et demi ok on fait
un pari merci beaucoup à vous trois
bonne soirée au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI